all right uh
one of the things that will happen march
13 the window opens on trades and it's
it's clear that the steelers would like
to trade receiver antonio brown the
problem is antonio brown is engaged in
some behaviors that could make a team
not all that inclined to bring antonio
brown to town most recently news of a
domestic incident from last month with
allegations of misconduct directed to
brown he allegedly pushed down the
mother of one of his children and and he
wasn't arrested but the nfl told me
yesterday they're looking into it right
even though you weren't arrested you can
still get yourself suspended as ezekiel
elliott found out and as kareem hunt
eventually will learn when he gets
suspended because that video came out
months after an allegation had emerged
in february so
what do you do with antonio brown at
this point chris because if i'm thinking
about trading for him i'm very leery
about the possibility that out of the
blue the guy's going to get suspended or
he's going to be on the commissioner
exempt list i'm otherwise not going to
get my value out of him and you can't
rule out the possibility that somebody's
going to sell a video to tmz at some
point well yeah sure certainly i mean
and then i'll start off like right where
you started do we know for sure that
pittsburgh definitely wants to get rid
of them i i'll just say this if i was
running a football team as a gm for any
of the uh franchises in the nfl and as
we know i'm not but if i was
i wouldn't touch antonio brown with a
10-foot pole i just wouldn't not at this
point of his career i understand he's
still a really good football player i
get that he'll be 31 in july uh i do uh
you know as i've told you a little bit
and on air i do think antonio brown's
lost a step to a degree doesn't still
mean he's not awesome but he's still i
don't think as explosive as he was two
years ago three years ago he is at the
age where a smaller receiver that's
based on speed and quicks like himself
starts to fall it starts to go the wrong
way i understand there's a lot of
production but at the same time this is
a guy that's been a loose cannon there's
no other way to put this over the last
few years whether it's blow ups on the
sidelines facebook from the from the
locker room what we saw this year uh i
just would think any gm or coach out
there is going to look at antonio brown
and go man do i really want to bring him
here and then uh be accused of not you
know having good institutional control
like we talk about with mike tomlin and
it's really because of just antonio
brown
so i don't know mike i mean i don't know
how you feel at the end of the day i'm
gonna bet money he's right back in
pittsburgh
well four weeks ago today owner art
rooney the second i think made it clear
that they were launching an auction for
antonio brown by saying in one breath we
can't imagine any set of circumstances
where he's back and then essentially
opening the door to a trade hammering
the for sale sign into the yard the
problem is i don't think they've gotten
the kind of offers that they thought
they would you know if you can get two
or three teams to the table and they
start bidding each other up you end up
getting a nice return for antonio brown
that hasn't happened and we touched on
this last week and stats and i discussed
this earlier in the program the idea
that antonio brown doesn't want to be
there and i interviewed terrell owens
the friday before super bowl week and
it didn't create a whole lot of traction
because it was a friday afternoon and by
monday we were in atlanta and everything
reset but
owens said he's been mentoring antonio
brown and i got the very clear
impression from t.o that brown wants out
so
how do you
how do you play this where the guy wants
out so the first thing you got to do is
convince him to stay how do you convince
him to stay but also vow to hold him
accountable for any type of misbehavior
moving forward i don't think you can
harmonize those two positions oh antonio
please please please please stay are you
going to stay you want to stay
we'll do everything we can to make you
happy okay good you're staying now
listen mister you better shape up right
now or you're going to be in big trouble
i mean you can't make those two sides of
the coin work it's impossible so i think
the steelers have to move on ed
buschetta the pittsburgh post gazette
has a column where he argues it's time
for the steelers to move on and frankly
when you consider the symbiosis that
often exists between the paper of record
in an nfl city and the nfl team that's
right it's entirely possible the
steelers asked him to do it right to lay
the foundation for what's next yes
because after this domestic violence
incident now and having to worry about a
possible suspension it could be see you
later antonio we don't want to get stuck
paying you 13 million this year while
you're on the commissioner's exempt list
yeah i mean i think that will be the big
thing that goes on now is where does
this investigation go that's gonna haul
all procedures all conversations because
no one's gonna want to touch him if they
don't know if he's gonna be suspended
for three four games two games whatever
it may be the other thing is this i mean
first of all i just look at it like this
like antonio brown the only place he's
going to get
away with some of the antics he's gotten
away with to this point in his career
is pittsburgh still now pittsburgh to
your point if they want to harmonize
this they're going to have to lay it on
the line and basically say like listen
if you're late we are going to fine you
to the maximum amount that the league
and the nfl pa and the current cba will
allow us to that's the first thing and
it's really the only thing they're going
to be able to do here but they have
managed the personality to a degree over
here over the years
so i would say that but the biggest
thing mike
is
okay
21 million dollars in dead money if they
let him go if they trade him whatever it
is that comes back to them and 21
million dollars as you know or anyone
that follows the salary cap in football
that's like three or four maybe five
quality starters on your football team
and that's hard to swallow i think as a
front office for an owner for a mike
tomlin and any of that so i do i just
see i still think that there's going to
be a little bit of a slow market for him
and i think he's gonna realize man i'm
gonna pain in the butt uh and maybe i
can make some things you know amicable
between the steelers and himself once
again and but i don't think anything's
gonna get done until this current
incident gets figured out
i've seen nothing from antonio brown
over the last month that has made me
think that he's going to take any
responsibility for where things are it's
not his fault lies are being told about
him so he says big interview is coming
even though we still have yet to hear
when it is who it's with yeah and when
we'll find out about it but but here's
one point right as to the 21 million
dollar cap charge they will take if they
move on from him if they keep him it's
going to cost 22 million under the cap
and they're gonna have to pay him 13
million dollars so
i mean
look if he's on the roster and he
actually costs more in cap dollars than
if he's off the roster and you have to
pay him 13 million where otherwise you
pay him zero i think it's very easy to
justify moving on and i know that's a
big number but again it's an even bigger
number if you keep him and if they're at
the point where we're done with the
distractions we're done with the issues
we're done with the drama we're just
done with this guy and you talked about
finding him to the maximum again he
doesn't want to be there
it's back to the point i made earlier
how do you convince him to stay and then
threaten to find him anytime he's late
it's just not worth it at this point i
think they should say hey look we got
more than we ever thought we would get
out of a guy who was a sixth round pick
back in 2010. it's our fault to a
certain extent that he became who he is
because we didn't squash on this when it
first emerged so we're going to say
thanks for the memories see you later
we're going to get the best deal we can
you know they once traded super bowl mvp
san antonio homes for a fifth round pick
i believe it was yes to the jets it was
either a four or five i think it was a
five so you get what you can and you
move on and i think that's what they
should do and i think it'll happen
during the draft chris i think that that
there's gonna be a team that is
targeting a receiver in round one
doesn't get him and says all right third
round pick fourth round pick whatever
for antonio brown yeah i i don't i i
think that would be about the timing i
would think that would be about the time
in the nfl basic statement on the
investigation and things that happened
there uh to where pittsburgh can move
them because they're going to want to
answer about it so they have a little
leverage in the trade and if if you do
trade them it's going to take you know i
just think it teams with a coach with a
strong personality and knows how to deal
with personalities that's that's the
other thing that's going to take as well
i think of a guy like john gruden out in
oakland who you know might want to make
a splash and free agency and get a guy
in there to ignite you know his team the
fan base all of that you know i think
about a kyle shanahan out in san
francisco they certainly have the money
to do it they know how to use receivers
all of those things but i'll say the
same thing i said to all you know to
start this i mean it's it's you got to
be careful with this guy right now and i
think he knows it and that's why he's
gone off radar and i think still just
when i hear little comments from other
people we were just with juju smith
schuster right last week at the super
bowl he still thinks there's a chance to
salvage the relationship you know i am
one that i think pittsburgh and antonio
brown can salvage it because i just
think they're they're both a little
renegade-ish and they'll both figure out
how to how to make this work somehow and
it'll never be perfect but to your point
with all the money they're gonna spend
to let him go well i'd rather pay him
that money to sit there and perform for
the pittsburgh steelers if if i'm then
i'm certainly thinking about it
juju also thought that le'veon bell is
going to be back so i don't i don't know
that i trust right juju's barometer i
hear that player retention
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports